joining me now Steve Malloy from the
energy and environment legal Institute
he's also a former Trump member of the
EPA transition team Steve what's really
going on here let's just focus on meat
then we're going to get to fossil fuels
they're obsessed with meat production
what's that really about well they
imagined that meat production is
responsible for 20% of the global
warming that's happening and of course
that's not true but they don't really
care um you know they've been after
every aspect of Our Lives everything we
you know are we're we work uh what we
eat what we drive what kind of
electricity we use all these things
every aspect of Our Lives all the way
down to what kind of toilet paper use
they want to tell us what to do but they
are never going to give up meat just
like during covid they never G gave up
their fancy dinners at The French
Laundry they didn't stop traveling to
the Bahamas wherever their vacation
homes are so they're never going to give
up meat they want regular people to have
less and be happy with less and have
fewer choices correct of course the
elites like John KY are never going to
give up their jet travel their their
meat Al Gore said he wasn't going to
give up cheeseburgers but they expect us
to they expect us to give up everything
for the climate they don't really care
they get a pass do cows and goats and
and sheep do they what is it the
flatulence is that what causes yeah the
methane but of course methane is
irrelevant to climate but they don't
care now Steve according to the guardian
today Secretary General of the UN a good
friend of yours Antonio gutterz has
called fossil fuel production the poison
bus route of the climate crisis and that
it should be dismantled and you heard
John KY we have to get the urgency to
dismantle it and they're mad that the
United States this year has actually had
more fossil fuel oil and gas production
than I think we've ever had which is
this past year sure we have record
fossil fuel production now as does China
as does the whole world look this is
this scam is 35 years old we are burning
more fossil fuel than ever before
emissions are up 50% since 1988 when the
climate hooks began
um it's just not you know this is not
about emissions it's about control over
that 35e period you know emissions have
gone way up so has their control now
they don't care about emissions
ultimately they just want to control how
we live and that goes with the EVS right
so New Jersey bans the sale of of gas
powerered cars in 2035 California's
doing it even Virginia has provision
that's going to steamroll they hate cars
because cars give us freedom okay so
they're going to make us relying on
China for cars you know you can't build
an e is gone is it not our car industry
is going to be gone yeah if we do the EV
rout well we're g EVS are totally
dependent on China as soon as CH as soon
as China invades Taiwan and we say
anything that's G to be the end of cars
yeah well they get rid of the Trump
tariffs they're really gone Steve great
to see you as always hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else